MOVEMENT.
WE TOOK A PAUSE TO TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK AND WHAT WE FOUND THIS
INTERESTING, AND WE'VE GOT IT.
JUST AHEAD.
AHEAD.
A MAN WHO JUST MONTHS AGO WAS
SEEN AS ONE OF HIS CLOSEST
ALLIES AND ADVISORS.
YESTERDAY, TRUMP SAID THAT
WHITE HOUSE BACK IN AUGUST.
NOW THE PRESIDENT ISSUING LEGAL
THREATS AGAINST BANNON.
BANNON GOT A LETTER THREATENING
A LAWSUIT FOR ALLEGED VIOLATIONS
OF A CONFIDENTIALITY AGREEMENT
HE ALLEGEDLY SIGNED.
WHAT TO MAKE OF ALL OF THIS?
WHITE HOUSE, VERY FEW ARE.
THIS ONE ACTUALLY IS.
HE HAS BEEN ADVISING TRUMP FOR
MORE THAN THREE DECADES.
HE WAS CAMPAIGN MANAGER OF HIS
URGE THE PRESIDENT TO RUN FOR
OFFICE THIS TIME, AND HE SERVED
ON THE CAMPAIGN DURING ITS
CRITICAL EARLY MONTHS.
AND CALLED HIM A STONE HAD BEEN
CALLED LOSER, BUT THEIR
ROGER, THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT IS THIS
FUNDAMENTALLY ABOUT.
FROM AN OUTSIDERS PERSPECTIVE,
IT APPEARS TO BE A DEBATE ABOUT
WHO CAN TAKE CREDIT FOR THE
UNEXPECTED WIN IN 2016 2016.
STEVE BANNON HAS TAKEN CREDIT
FOR THAT.
THE PRESIDENT BELIEVES HE DID IT
THE PRESIDENT BELIEVES HE DID I
IT.
TO WHAT EXTENT DID BANNON
CONTRIBUTE TO THE VICTORY?
>> WELL, I WANTED TO GIVE
STEVE BANNON THE CREDIT BENEFIT
OF THE DOUBT, PARTICULARLY GIVEN
THE REPUTATION OF MICHAEL WOLFF,
THE REPUTATION OF MICHAEL WOLFFB
THE REPUTATION OF MICHAEL WOLFFT
GIVEN THE COMMENTS THAT
ACT OF BETRAYAL, AND IT IS ALSO
A COMPLETE MISUNDERSTANDING OF
DONALD TRUMP.
AND   IN DONALD TRUMP'S WORLD, I
AND   IN DONALD TRUMP'S WORLD, N
TRUMP WORLD, THERE IS NO
KARL ROVE.
DONALD TRUMP IS VERY MUCH HIS
OWN WORLD.
HIS HIS OWN MAN, HIS OWN
STRATEGIST, HIS OWN
SPEECHWRITER, HIS OWN PRESS
GREATEST SINGLE SALESMAN IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
AND THE PRESIDENT'S AGENDA ON
WHICH HE WAS ELECTED, I SHOULD
SAY'S PLATFORM, WAS DETERMINED
LONG BEFORE STEVE BANNON JOINED
THE CAMPAIGN IT WAS DETERMINED
ONE MAN, DONALD TRUMP.
HE IS A PHENOMENA, A FORCE OF
NATURE, BUT HE CANNOT BE HANDLED
OR MANAGED, HE'S NOT A PUPPET,
AND HE NEVER WILL BE.
>> Tucker: BANNON ARGUES THAT
HE PUT TRUMP'S IMPULSES WITHIN A
FRAMEWORK THAT ALLOWED HIM TO
ERECT.
I KNEW BANNON FROM ANOTHER LIFE
WHEN WE RAN RIVAL PUBLICATIONS.
I CAN'T ASSESS HIS SKILL AS A
POLITICAL STRATEGIST.
IS HE A POLITICAL GENUS AND
CAMPAIGNS ARE NO?
>> I WOULD ARGUE IT IS
DONALD TRUMP WAS A POLITICAL
GENIUS.
HERE IS SOMEBODY WHO OVERCAME
ENORMOUS ODDS, MASSIVELY
VICTORY AS IN AMERICAN POLITICAL
HISTORY.
NOW, THE TRUMP FIVE FOR WELL
SETTLED ON LONG BEFORE
STEVE BANNON JOINED THE CAMPAIGN
STEVE BANNON JOINED THE CAMPAIG
CAMPAIGN.
AND IT APPEARS THAT STEPHEN
MILLER HELPED THE PRESIDENT
ARTICULATED.
BUT THE AGENDA IS TRUMP, THE
DRIVE TO WIN IS TRUMP.
THE POPULIST CAMPAIGN IS ALL
TRUMP.
JUST TAKING THE TITLE OF CHIEF
>> Tucker: .
THE IDEA WAS THAT, AFTER THE
THE WHITE HOUSE, THE REMINDER OF
HE IS BEING ATTACKED.
WHY IS THAT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE MOVEMENT IS
BIGGER THAN ANY ONE PERSON.
I ASKED SIX PEOPLE ON THE WAY
INTO THE FOX STUDIO HERE
EVERY SINGLE ONE KNEW WHO
DONALD TRUMP WAS AN EVERY SINGLE
ONE KNEW ABOUT HIS EFFORTS TO
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
THEN YOU'LL GET TO THE
SPECIFICS.
NO, DONALD TRUMP JR.'S MEETING
IMPROPER.
STEVE IS NEITHER A LAWYER NOR AN
EXPERIENCED POLITICAL
STRATEGIST.
THAT MEETING IS A
NOTHING-BURGER.
IT LOOKS MORE AND MORE LIKE A
WAS IN THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY AT
SO I DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND BUT
WOULD MOTIVATE SAFE TO SAY THOSE
THINGS WHEN IT IS THE PRESIDENT
WHO HAS GIVEN HIM THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SERVICE.
WELL, YOU COULD CHALK IT UP TO
ANGER OVER BEING FIRED IF HE HAD
MADE THESE COMMENTS AFTER HE WAS
TERMINATED, BUT BASED ON MY
RESEARCH, HE SAID THOSE THINGS
PAYROLL.
>> Tucker: FINALLY, WHY THE
LEGAL THREATS?
I DON'T THINK ANYONE BELIEVES
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO SUE
STEVE BANNON FOR VIOLATING AN
NDA OR THE AUTHOR OF THIS BOOK.
DOESN'T THIS JUST CALL ATTENTION
TO THE BOOK, HELP SELL BOOKS?
ISN'T IT DOWN TO THE BENEFIT OF
THE AUTHOR?
WHY WOULD YOU INSTRUCT YOUR
LAWYERS TO DO SOMETHING LIKE
THAT?
>> I'M NOT SURE ABOUT THE
EFFICACY.
THE TRUMP BASE WILL STICK WITH
DONALD TRUMP AS LONG AS HE KEEPS
HISTORY.
A SOLID CONSERVATIVE ON THE U.S.
LEVELS.
THAT IS THE TRUMP AGENDA.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT SURE ABOUT